here's a man waiting in the wings
armed and ready to take his party out of
13 years of opposition
the man the poles think will be our next
prime minister for the pitch today for
change we're going to roll up our
sleeves fix the problems and improve our
country
we can't keep expecting the British
people to just suck it up
and there was a policy pledge for
devolution
we will spread control out of
Westminster
devolve new powers over employment
support transport energy climate change
housing culture Child Care provision and
how councils run their finances when it
comes to the big issues that are
impacting people right now NHS pay the
strikes it's not clear what you're
saying Beyond saying that you would do
better job than the Tories you say
you're not willing to get your big
checkbook out but how are you going to
fix those problems every year we go into
an NHS crisis it just gets worse and
worse and worse and so we're in the
worst one ever now and that's sticking
plaster politics that's why we've said
that we will have a fully funded plan to
bring in thousands and thousands more
nurses more doctors because in the end
that's the only way we're going to get
out of this
another day and another party leader
sets out their school the challenge for
Kirsten will be showing that he's not
just capitalizing on Tory turbo that he
has a direction for this party and can
tell the public what he really stands
for hands up if you know who kirst armor
is
that politician I wouldn't vote for the
conservatives because I want a lot to
change down here and I feel like
this area isn't really good so the
conservatives will make it worse there's
no point of view for them because we've
been asking for the same thing for so
long and they're not doing anything
about it yeah I feel like even though we
are young the time that we grew up in
with like labor a lot was different to
them now a lot has changed for the worse
right but is simply being an alternative
to the conservatives enough recent polls
put the labor lead at around 20 percent
now that is a large lead by historical
standards but we also know they would
need to achieve an average swing in
constituencies along the same lines that
Tony Blair achieved in 1997 which was
the highest Wing that anyone has ever
achieved in British political history
yesterday the pitch from the PM was all
about competence it's harder to pledge
change when your party's been in power
for a decade what the Prime Minister put
forward were five very clear measurable
goals that we will pursue in government
and we can be held to account for what
we saw from Kia stama as I say was a
whole load of nothing
we could be two years from a general
election but the campaign's starting gun
may just have been fired by the Prime
Minister and the man hoping to replace
him Ali fought skew Sky News